en mayo embalses como este por lo
general están llenos de agua pero este
año lo único que queda es un pozo seco y
agrietado jong-un frío es el dueño de
esta hacienda en california central este
último año varios condados han sido
testigos de condiciones de sequía
excepcional es el tipo de aridez más
severo esta fuente de agua nunca ha
estado seca en mayo yo nunca lo había
visto fue un año demasiado seco cada
gota de lluvia que caía al suelo era
absorbida y nada se recolectó ni se
acumuló en un embalse como éste
ha habido la mitad de lluvia de lo
normal y muy poca nieve en las montañas
de sierra nevada
las vacas han tenido dificultades para
encontrar sombra y los granjeros han
tenido que reducir sus rebaños tal vez
hay un tercio de la cantidad habitual
que tenemos de pasto como no hay
suficiente alimento hemos tenido que
deshacernos de los animales entre el 20
y el 25 por ciento del rebaño
y el ganado está sediento porque hay una
escasez de agua en un valle que depende
mucho de la agricultura los árboles se
extienden en el horizonte cargados de
naranjas duraznos y pistachos
[Música]
dos tercios de las frutas de eeuu son
cultivadas aquí al igual que el 80% de
las almendras consumidas en el mundo
pero durante las últimas semanas los
campos de almendros se han visto así
como cementerios los árboles son
arrancados a una velocidad sin
precedentes a causa de una falta de
riego danielle hardwicke dirige los
cultivos aquí dice que sencillamente no
hay suficiente agua para que los árboles
crezcan con normalidad me parte el
corazón no tenemos suficiente agua y no
podemos mantener vivos estos árboles se
trazarían demasiado y se les haría
demasiado daño no sería posible dejarlos
en el suelo dejarlos seguir así
quedarían demasiado perjudicados serían
recuperables
esta máquina arranca 5000 árboles el
equivalente al 15 por ciento de la
producción de almendras una situación
sin precedentes en esta granja estos
árboles están en la mitad de su ciclo de
vida son adultos hermosos se encuentran
justo en el momento en el que deberían
estar produciendo comida para todo el
mundo
los almendros requieren mucha agua por
eso la granja de danielle no puede
permitir que se pierda una sola gota
como pueden ver aquí no está mojado no
hay acumulación de agua no hay agua
quieta ni nada el agua tiene una
cantidad exacta que se trae a este pozo
en el fuego los agricultores han puesto
en barbecho cientos de hectáreas de
tierra aunque regarlas puede ser costoso
el agua que fluye hacia este canal desde
las montañas está reservada para las
ciudades
así que en el valle los granjeros han
estado cavando pozos para sacar agua
subterránea
[Música]
stybar zur ha trabajado en este negocio
desde que tenía 14 años
por pekín
las personas están entrando en pánico
están poniéndose ansiosas no tienen agua
y deben regar sus cultivos tenemos
cuatro excavadoras y tres camiones bomba
funcionando no podemos atender la
demanda
no hay límites para la cantidad de pozos
que los granjeros pueden construir o
para la cantidad de agua que puedan
sacar steve arthur está acabando cada
vez más hondo en busca de más de un año
el agua puede quedarse ahí pero apenas
haya otro año de sequía lentamente irá
bajando con un año de humedad se
equilibra pero siempre está bajando
pero pueden los granjeros y la
agricultura intensiva en realidad ser
parte del problema esto es lo que rebeca
quintana teme es una local que vive en
medio de estos inmensos campos están
sacando a todo el agua y se está
agotando están provocando una crisis al
mantener las bombas en funcionamiento
las 24 horas del día
todavía no hay restricciones para los
residentes pero muchos utilizan
botellones de agua potable porque el
agua de la llave se ha contaminado y
esta es la zona cero del agua más
contaminada en el país en declive la
poca agua que sale de los grifos solo
puede usarse para lavar los platos o
para las duchas contaminación reducción
de los niveles de agua sequía
todo esto en uno de los valles más
fértiles de eeuu